Okay, greetings everyone. So, uh it is
June 5th, 2026. We're here uh with the
fundamentals of active inference
textbook group session two on uh chapter
4. So, we're going to be going over the
first half of chapter 4 in this session
uh as we did in Daniel's session last
time. So, if I share my screen here,
let's go entire screen. share
one thing uh just quickly of note I
haven't yet put the um the diagrams in
into the coder page itself uh for the
figures so if you go to chapter 4 what
there is currently I'll get rid of that
is we have the you know we have the
actual sections of the chapter the
objectives chapter nutshell all the good
stuff I put in before content breakdown
what's core and what's not things like
that and the first two subsections have
their chapter maps. Okay, so we do that
same sort of analysis again within the
subsections. So I think we're going to
go over subsections 4.1 and point two
and three today. Uh and that will cover
most of the chapter actually uh all of
the the big ideas in chapter 4 and then
the remaining subsections when we come
back next time that kind of generalize
the ideas and and take them in in
interesting directions. So this is a
very this is a really cool chapter. This
is actually quite a milestone uh once we
get through chapter 4. This is the first
time really we're going to see um the
the actual mathematical machinery of
active inference. Okay, which is to say
variational inference. This is kind of
what we do in active inference. You know
we're still limited to the perception
only case. So we're not considering
actions just yet. But in some sense this
is the first real taste of what we what
we do in active efforts. we do
variational inference. So that's what
we're going to cover this uh this
session. So as I say the the the content
is there just now and the first two
subjections are there. I need to add the
third one. There's some animations I
want to share with you later that I've
created using manim but the figures
aren't there yet. I'll have to add them
in. So what we'll be doing to visualize
things is I have access to a repository
uh that Sanjie has has given us
facilitators access to that that has all
the figures. So we do have them all
here. Uh so for instance we have the
chapter map.
Here we go. So this is the map of all of
the the subsections and everything.
Hopefully everyone can see my screen. I
just want to maybe come back check the
chat see if there are any problems like
that.
I think we're okay. All right. Please do
interrupt if um if I'm I think I'm
sharing my screen and I'm not actually.
So okay. So really real briefly, let's
just let's just kind of orient ourselves
with respect to where we are and what
we've done. Uh so chapters 1 to three
again I've repeated this several times
now, but you know they were very much
about we're going to start out with the
simplest possible case of perception
that we can think of. Okay, we're not
going to deal with action at all just
yet. And indeed in chapter 4, we're
still not going to be dealing with
actions. So we're we're spinning up the
machinery gradually by which we're going
to be able to talk about um the
operation of active inference per se. So
we haven't really even got to active
inference yet in chapters one through
three and indeed through four. What
we've been doing is we've been building
up the the mathematical background
necessary in order to be able to talk
about how action comes in. But we
haven't done that yet. and chapter four
will be the end of that um yoga and
training in in the the constituent
mathematics. So let's have a bit of a
look here. Chapters one through three
it's it's been about Beijian inference.
Okay, how do we do Beijian inference?
How do we approximate Beijian inference?
Um how do we update beliefs about latent
states of the world on the basis of
sensory evidence? Okay, and we're just
observing stuff. We're not acting just
yet. That's been the story for chapters
one through three. And last time we saw
the culmination of chapter 3 was this
algorithm called the expectation
maximization algorithm wherein we were
able to kind of solve the chicken and
egg problem that is that arises uh when
you're having to learn or rather infer
hidden states and also learn model
parameters. Okay. So you know typically
you have to do both of these things at
the same time and in order to infer
hidden states you have to know the model
parameters and then to learn the model
parameters you have to know the hidden
states and expectation maximization
gives us a way to kind of break that
problem down into the constituent steps
that the two steps basically you trade
off assuming you know the model
parameters with expectation you then
perform inference and vice versa. So
that's what we saw last time at the end
of chapter three. Um that's great. Uh
that's actually very central to the the
style of thing that we'll be doing going
forward. But there's a very important
assumption that is made in expectation
maximization which is that you know you
are able to calculate the exact
posterior. Basically uh that's a key
assumption in being able to use
expectation maximization. And in general
what we're going to see in chapter 4
going forward is that typically you
can't do this. typically you cannot
actually evaluate the true posterior
using basian inference. So you know
we've looked at ways of approximating
true Beijian inference by means of grid
approximation
uh and things like this but those are
radical radical simplifications uh to
you know the general case and they're
not going to allow us to do the kind of
inference we want to do for bigger
problems. Okay we've been considering a
very very tiny problem which is this
this food selection thing. So what we're
going to do is we're going to talk about
model evidence today. That's the thing
that we're trying to uh that's the bug
bear the kind of problem that is faced
that we that we are faced with when
we're doing Beijian inference is we need
to evaluate the model evidence. We've
seen that this is this is what it is to
marginalize our model on the basis of um
observations that we could get from the
world. Usually this is impossible. uh
and there's a whole story about how we
can how we can approximate or bound
model evidence using this quantity
called free energy variational free
energy. So this is the first time we're
going to talk about variational free
energy. It's a very very pivotal point.
Um there's then you know 4.5 4.6 they
get into various ways of talking about
how to minimize variational free energy
or certain assumptions that are made
when we are minimizing it. But this
first session is going to be about
motivating what it is where it comes
from what it's all about basically. So,
we're going to go 4.1, 4.2, and I think
4.3 today, which is going to be good.
That [clears throat] is the plan. Any
questions so far? Is there anything
anyone is unclear about or would like to
raise [clears throat]
>> for
for new joiners and those who have very
B
theorem evidence is P of E, right? It's
the
not the
>> well just clarifying I slightly remember
what model evidence is. I I think it was
like the P of E which was not the exact
answer to to the
this
theorem because when we when we do the
base probability it was the idea was to
compute the probability that hypothesis
still holds up given the new evidence
right like that's that's the core idea
>> well yes
>> I will I'll show you uh you know perhaps
some equations and so on but the idea is
that the model evidence uh is our
marginal belief about observations
across every possible state of the world
that could have generated an
observation. Um that's the thing that is
the model evidence basically. Um so it's
p of y we've been using y to denote
observations and x to denote hidden
states. Um we'll get into that now I
think. So let's try let's try and have a
look at
that
>> ju just one more quick clarification. So
essentially the the term you use model
evidence comes from
theorem right it's that's where it
comes. It's not some it doesn't mean
anything different.
>> Okay that's a good point. So model
evidence very much the idea is that we
have a model right? So we are using a
model to perform bijian inference um by
which we can update beliefs according to
our observations. So here's a model here
right this is
I just want to get this right in terms
of the numbering this is 42 or 4.12
rather um so yeah we have a model about
observations how observations are
generated that's our likelihood model
this one here and then we have prior on
hidden states obviously and we have our
linear generating function so this is a
story about how we think observations
are generated it is a model about the
generative process um model evidence is
are
the the the likelihood that we should
say that an observation was generated
from the the uh generative process that
we think is there. Okay, so this is a
story about what we think the generative
process is alike. It's like this here.
It's a linear relationship. Um we could
be wrong about that. Okay, the model
evidence is a kind of a score about how
right or wrong we are in that sense.
So we're going to motivate this more
going forward because the whole chapter
is about model evidence and about the
problems associated with um calculating
model evidence. So that is very much
what we're going to get into. I want to
just show if I go back here as always in
everything that we do we need to start
off with bases rule. Okay. So this is
where we start in the chapter. So this
is obviously we have our posterior
belief about hidden states given
observations. What is this? It is our
generative model divided by the model
evidence. That is how we get our
posterior. Okay. Exactly. Precisely
straight up Bas's rule. And we do the
key thing the key thing that we need to
do in order to do this correctly is we
need to marginalize our model across all
possible hidden states to get the the
probability of an observation in
general.
Let's check something here real quick.
And that that is exactly what that is
where the [clears throat] model evidence
comes from this marginalization
procedure. Just checking something here.
All right.
Very nice. Now
I want to move the thing is
uh so we saw we saw that we can't
in the general case uh the like the
kinds of problems that we've been
dealing with. So this kind of problem
here
where there's only really one hidden
state uh although we have generalized to
the case of multivaried hidden states
before the problem is very very simple
and so we have been able to use bases
rule exactly we've been able to perform
this calculation kind of no problem
right we've chopped up the uh the
generative process into a number of
discrete uh points and we've just been
able to evaluate this thing down here
usually this is completely impossible
We have no hope in no hope of doing this
whatsoever. So the question is okay well
we need to evaluate our posterior. How
are we going to do that given that we
actually can't perform this calculation
down here in the general case. That's
the the key thing about this chapter. We
want we want to do this but we really
can't. And the key idea is that we're
going to turn this problem because what
is this problem by the way? I'm going to
I'm going to ask I'm going to call for
members of the audience audience
participation. What actually is the
problem that well I need to admit Andrew
what is the problem that we're doing
that we're solving you mean
>> in terms of bijian theorem or or or
implication for active inference
>> from what I remember it's the the core
idea of basian theorem is that basian
rule right what do you call it you you
have a hypothesis about something and
you you get a new evidence
that might change your hypothes. So your
idea is can you compute the probability
that whatever you assumed your prior
still holds up given this new evidence
and this result this computation is
called still posterior
>> correct posterior probability. So what
what we get in is an observation and uh
because I I want to be careful about
distinguishing model evidence from the
evidence of our senses, right? So we get
an observation and yeah know you're
you're exactly correct. What I was
gesturing to is that the problem the
kind of problem that we're we're solving
with Bas's rule is an inference problem.
Okay, active inference, right? We're
doing inference. That's the sort of
problem we're dealing with. Here's the
problem. The problem with that problem
is that this inference problem is now
too hard. So come back here. We can't
really solve this problem basically. So
here's the key idea. This is the real
key move in in chapter 4. We're going to
turn this problem into a different kind
of problem. Instead of solving an
inference problem, we're going to solve
an optimization problem. Okay, this is
going to sound a little bit weird at
first, but the idea is we're not going
to do straight up inference. We're going
to sort of pretend that we're doing
inference by doing a slightly different
problem instead. That's the the key
move. Okay, this is where variational
free energy is going to come in.
Uh so he uh if we go to 4.2
this is uh so this is on page 79 4.13
4.20
[clears throat]
it is important to show because this is
the first time we see a very very
important quantity
which will show up time and again.
I don't like the way the coder or orders
these things.
Here we go. Okay. Very nice.
All right. Let's not try and get too
uh freaked out about what we're looking
at here. The idea is that we're going to
pretend that we know what the posterior
is. Okay? We're going to start out with
a guess. Um and we're going to make that
guess better and better across time.
Okay? That's what it means by
optimization. So, we start out with some
sort of guess about what posterior is
the true posterior. Uh and then we're
going to make that guess better is is
the idea. That's what it is to do
optimization. And we've already seen uh
a few optimization procedures already.
We saw that with gradient descent,
right? Where you start out on some
energy landscape.
So,
and what you do is you kind of follow
the contours of the energy landscape
until you get to the bottom in some
sense. So, this is what we saw. We saw
this in chapter 2. We also saw it again
in chapter 3. That is a that is a kind
of optimization procedure. And the idea
here is that we're going to do a very
similar sort of thing when it comes to
optimizing the posterior belief itself.
We're now going to turn that infant's
problem into an optimization problem.
Okay. So that raises a question though
which is if I come back to the equation,
what how are we actually going to tell
how good our posterior belief is or our
approximate posterior belief? We need
some way now to score how good an
approximate posterior belief is. Okay,
that's the core kind of issue that we're
going to have to deal with. Um, it's
going to turn it's going to turn out
eventually that the the way that we
score our posterior beliefs is with
respect to this quantity called
variational free energy. But I haven't
quite explained where that comes from
just yet.
Where he goes where he where he
initially sort of starts is by saying we
need some way to obviously compare
probability distributions. Okay? Because
our our approximate posterior belief it
is a probability distribution. There is
a true one out there somewhere and we're
trying to approximate that. So we need a
notion that allows us to compare
probability distributions. Uh there's
there's a couple of different ways of
doing this, but kind of the most
canonical and one of the the most
central ways that you will see this uh
instantiated in a lot of probability
theory is with something called the KL
divergence. All right, the coolback
labeler divergence. This is a score of
the sort of average difference between
two probability distributions and it's a
way of saying how different they are to
one another. And you're looking on the
screen just now. This is the expression
uh the mathematical expression for the
KL divergence. So you read this by
saying look we've got divergence KL
between this thing and this thing. So
the two vertical bars separate the two
probability distributions at issue. So
what you're looking at is the kale
divergence between this P distribution P
of A I don't know what A is doesn't
matter and Q of A. This is the first
time that we've seen a very crucial uh
piece of notation which is that almost
always in active inference we notate our
approximate posterior beliefs not with P
of [snorts] something but with Q. Okay.
So usually when you see a Q that's your
approximate posterior belief. So this is
the KL divergence between some P
distribution and some approximate
posterior distribution. Okay, that's
what we're looking at here. Now it's
defined as the integral of the uh first
distribution times the log of the ratio
of the first to the second distribution.
Doesn't matter precisely what that means
just yet other than to say that it is a
measure of the divergence or difference
between the probability distributions.
One crucial thing is that it's not a
distance. Okay, so technically, you
know, huristically you might say it's a
measure of the distance between two
distributions. It's not that. There's a
reason why it's not that. I don't really
want to talk about why it's not that.
Um, nevertheless, it's a measure of the
difference or divergence. Okay, so
banish the idea of distance from your
head just for the the moment. Here's
another way of notating it
mathematically. So this is exactly the
same equation you've seen before just
expressed with respect to expectations.
Now, so you can this is precisely the
same thing. What is the K divergence
between P and Q? It's the expectation of
the difference of the log of P and Q
under P. [laughter]
So, and again, if that if that raises
heckles, if you're not sure about what
that means, don't matter doesn't matter
too much other than to say that this is
merely another way that we can notate
the um the K divergence.
>> Great quick question here. Um
>> so this this E letter in in the equation
that you are just showing so the you
call it expectation.
Yes, by this letter for for a while now.
Is that like a short notation for
something like a
a different operation or or does it have
its own meaning essentially like a
>> the expectation this is a very central
uh concept. Um I'll just note as well
one place that would be really helpful
to go is in the appendix. I think it's
C1 or C2, I can't remember off the top
of my head, but C C2 does, you know, the
probability theory. Um, yeah,
absolutely. Very nice. Random variables,
probability functions, and in here
somewhere, he covers expectations and
expected random variables.
>> Do you know that? Thank you.
>> Yeah, that would be good. There you go.
C.2.6 on page 440, expected values. Very
good. Yeah. Yeah. So this is just a way
of notating the the average value of uh
a probability distribution with respect
to its outcomes. So it's as much as I
can say right now. Uh it is just a
different way of writing this.
That's just a different way of writing
this here. So please yeah do do go and
check out C2.6. I will also answer
questions uh if you put them in. So
chapter 4.
Uh we don't I don't know if we link just
now to the questions. Here we go. So
there aren't any questions for chapter
4, but if you add a new question, you
can do that here or in the questions
table. I will go through and uh answer
as well in in longer form detail.
So
thank you. Thank you for the live
questions too. I do like live questions
for sure. So okay. All right. So we've
seen that we need some way of scoring
our probability distributions and we're
going to use the kale divergence to do
that. That is everything so far. Now
that brings us to 4.2. Okay. So, uh or
rather I just want to quickly show 4.4
uh which is [clears throat]
here. There we go.
So, this is yet more confusing
mathematical notation. The idea is that
if we if we could do exact Beijian
inference, right, using our approximate
posterior belief, then the the true
posterior the probability of the hidden
state given our observation, it would be
exactly equal to the approximate
posterior belief that we get if we were
able to make the difference between the
approximate posterior and the true
posterior equal to zero.
So obviously if the difference between
the approximate and the true posterior
is zero then the approximate posterior
is exactly the true posterior and that
would be great. That would be the
perfect situation. That would be exactly
what we wanted. And this is just a
mathematical way of saying um that would
be the case. Okay. So don't get too hung
up on what this argument means here. But
that's that's going to set up how it is
that we can begin to talk about
minimizing the difference between the
approximate and true posterior.
So 4.2 two uh this is you know
estimating the posterior with
variational free energy this begins to
get into the weeds now about how we
actually start doing this process how we
start minimizing the uh the variational
posterior 4.20 I don't want that
uh the key thing is what happens is we
get 4.8 all right I want to show 4.8
So what he he says kind of nicely in the
text here, imagine that we have some
some kind of way of evaluating
um the difference between our true and
approximate posterior
uh or rather the the approximate
posterior and the generative model.
Okay, this function is what we're
actually going to be concerned with
because look at this. There's a problem
with 4.8.
Where's 4.8 again? or rather 4 point uh
is it 4.8? No, it is
4.4.
Can anyone tell me what the problem is
with 4.4? Oh, no. 4.44. I don't want
that.
Here we go. Here we go. There we go.
>> This is not very helpful.
>> The left hand side is in terms of the
right hand side. Uh the posterior on
both the left and right hand side.
>> Yeah. So like this is actually deeply
unhelpful. Uh because what we're saying
is look the true posterior would be
equal to whatever the approximate
posterior is if it was exactly the same
to the true posterior. Well that's nice
but that's completely unhelpful. Okay.
So the question is how are we going to
turn this expression into something that
is actually helpful because we we would
need to know the true posterior in order
to evaluate this equation here which
would be which would be absurd.
So very much 4.2 two is a way of kind of
showing us or expressing telling us how
we can turn this kind of silly problem
into an actual problem that we can begin
to solve. Uh and the key idea is that if
I go to 4.5
[clears throat] this one here we're
going to look at the relationship
between the trip posterior and the
generative model. Okay, obviously this
is just bases rule. We know that the
triposta is the generative model divided
by the model evidence. Okay, this is P
of Y. Now, a lot of times, and you'll
see this, this comes from physics. This
comes from a lot of places, the model
evidence is denoted by this number Z.
Okay, so Z is just whatever number you
need in order to normalize the
generative model to make sure that it is
equal to a probability. Okay. And it's
this thing, it's this Z that's usually
impossible for us to calculate. Okay.
All right. So, what we can do is we can
do a bit of mathematical yoga, right? we
go to or some some algebra and we go to
4.7.
Here we go. 4.7.
So without the Z, we know that there is
a relationship between the true
posterior and the generative model.
Okay, they're related to one another.
They're proportional to one another.
That's what this expression here means.
And they're exactly equal when you
divide the generative model by the
normalizer by the model evidence. So the
triple stereo times the model evidence
is equal to the generative model. Ah,
this is going to be interesting because
we want to know the true posterior but
we only know we only have access to our
generative model. Okay. And we we
certainly don't have access to the to
the model evidence. So we're seeing
we're beginning to now express things
that we don't know in terms of things
that we do know. We do know the general
model. We we create that. We specify
what it is.
So that allows us to say 4.7b. where he
says here from this we can conclude that
the generative model and posterior are
proportional to one another and the
ratio is described by the constant of
proportionality Z. Uh now this suggests
that although we cannot actually
calculate Z, if we had a way to
approximate it, it would also obtain an
approximation for the posterior
distribution.
We would also like our loss function to
be a function of distributions that we
can actually have access to, namely the
approximate posterior and the general
model. So the ideal loss function the
one that we really care about uh which
we'll denote as f and this is again
expression 4.8 this one here. So there's
some loss function we don't know what it
is yet. Uh it should satisfy this
equation here. It means that the
approximate posterior should be equal to
well sorry the true posterior should be
equal to the approximate posterior
that is that results in the minimum of
some function that involves the
approximate posterior and the generative
model. Okay.
And the reason is because these are
things that we actually have access to.
Okay. We have we have access to the
approximate posterior and the generative
model. And we know that there's a
relationship between the generative
model and the true posterior. But we
don't know what f is yet. Okay, that's
the thing that we uh we need to uh
settle now. What is this f going to be
that when we find the minimum of it
gives us the approximate posterior.
Uh so yeah, I mean he says you know in
equation 4.8 We're saying that we wish
to adjust the distribution Q until the
loss function is minimized and this loss
is whatever this F is
very much. Does suction function
actually exist? That's the the key
thing. It turns out yes and it's called
the variational free energy. So that's
where that comes from. We're going to
turn now to its definition. So 4.9A and
B. I don't want to there there is a way
to go through the mathematics here and
talk about where this comes from. So
this is just what we saw before. You
know we've got the kale divergence
between the approximate and true
posterior. It's equal to this expression
here. What you can do is you can now
substitute in the expression for the
true posterior involving the model
evidence and the generative model. Okay.
So what you do here
is you take P of X given Y and you
replace it with P of X and Y your
generative model divided by the model
evidence. And then using the rules of
logarithms, you end up with this
expression here.
This is very very very interesting. So
we're saying the kale divergence between
the approximate and true posterior is
equal to this thing here plus the log
model evidence. Now what's really cool
about this thing here is that we can
actually calculate this. This is the
approximate posterior and our generative
model. Those are two things that we have
access to. Excellent. And this
expression, this is a KL divergence.
It's an it's a logarithm. Sorry, it's an
integral of a distribution times the log
of that distribution divided by another.
So whatever this is, this is a KL
divergence right here. And that is
precisely the variational free energy.
So that's really cool. We're beginning
to see now a relationship between the
divergence between the approximate and
true in terms of this thing called the
VFE and the log model errors. Okay.
So and that's exactly what you have on
4.9 C this one here. So usually we
denote the variational free energy by
this script f here. So this is exactly
what I showed you before except now it's
a bit simplified. So the the K version
between the the approximate and true is
the VF plus the log model evidence.
Now we don't know the mod log model
evidence. It's too hard to calculate.
Okay. So this is still
kind of you know an interesting uh
development but you might not imagine
that it's particularly useful just yet.
However
there's a there's a very useful fact
which I want to go this is on page 81
now
uh I just need to find it here.
Yes. So the second term is known as the
log evidence or log z. Okay. So we're
going to equivocate between sometimes
you'll see log of P of Y. Sometimes
you'll see log of Z. Okay, it's exactly
the same thing. It's the log model
evidence. The denominator of basis
theorem is frequently referred to as
Beijian model evidence evidence or
marginal likelihood. These are all the
same names for the same thing. Um yes
yes yes.
And there's actually a lot of ways that
we can rearrange the expression for the
variational free energy. So this one
here
this is the variational free energy what
you're looking at this becomes 410
so 4.10 Can if I can find that?
It is important to show
Can I find it in time?
Uh, it'll be up here when it There we
go.
All right. So, this is what's known as
the G form. This is uh Sanjie's just
homegrown notation or or way of talking
about the the VF. uh this is the
expression for the variational free
energy that involves the generative
model this p of x and y down here. So
because it because it's expressed with
respect to the generative model we call
it the g form. There's actually a lot of
different forms of variational free
energy. There's different ways of
arranging things different ways of
spectralizing the same underlying thing
basically but this is the first aspect
that we're we're going to see here.
The really crucial part that
kind of ties this all together and that
allows us to have a way of minimizing
well have a way of approximating the
triple steer is that if we go back to uh
I want to see 4.9 well B or C it doesn't
really matter too much
67 8
9b
let's let's take six
the crucial property of the the KL
divergence is that it's always greater
than or equal to zero it's never
negative, right? So what does that mean?
It means that if we make the KL
divergence as close as possible to zero,
then we're going to have well, so okay,
let's back up.
Let's look at this one here. So the K
divergence between the approximate and
true posterior is the KL divergence
between the approximate posterior and
the generative model, which is to say
the variational free energy plus the log
model.
So if we can make the kale divergence
between the approximate posterior and
the generative model as small as
possible
this whole expression becomes very very
very close to the log model evidence and
that's great because then we have an
approximation for the log model evidence
and that allows us to then calculate
things and we can sort of do inference.
Again, that's the core kind of insight.
We that is to say that the variational
free energy bounds the log model
evidence effectively. You'll see this
notation come up a lot in the in the
literature.
That takes us to example 4.1 which I do
want to talk about. That's there's a lot
of moving parts right there. Is there
any are there any questions thus far? Is
there anything anyone would like to
comment on at this point?
Has anything been unclear?
I know it was when I first uh looked at
things.
Oh, thanks Andrew. You've added chapter
four slides. Beautiful.
Very, very good. Okay.
>> Yeah. Uh sorry, I was just a bit late
Frasier, but I was curious. Do you plan
to touch on uh Jensen's inequality
uh and that sort of piece? I think that
it
>> helps us understand like why are we
suddenly using these logs all over the
place, right? Like they don't feature in
Baz's original theorem. So what what's
going on with that? And you've
definitely hinted at the fact that we'll
be kind of using different aspects of
the mathematics that allow us to do this
variational inference. But uh yeah, I
wanted to bring that up. I'm actually
adding a slide about it in those slides
right now. So I don't want to detract
from your your current approach. Uh but
I just wanted to mention that.
>> No, fair enough. Thank you for the
slides as well that they will be very
useful. Yeah, we we we'll get to
Jensen's inequality I think uh as a
motivating example as to like yeah why
why all these logs and everything. Um
let's do maybe example 4.1 just real
quick and then we'll do kind of Jensen
which I think is that'll tie things
together very nicely. So if I go to so
we want equation 4.11. Now this where
we're actually going to do some
variational free energy minimization.
Now that's the uh the example. So 4.11.
Very nice. So here's our this is the
generative process. Again this is
exactly the same generative process that
we've seen many many times now. Linear
generating model. Okay. And we have our
hyperparameters. They are what they are.
Very nice. And we also have our
generative model 4.12.
I showed this before.
Again, this is I think identical to the
one that we've been using in chapter 3
for most of the time. The thing is
though, uh now we're going to cast this
problem in terms of variational free
energy minimization. So we're going to
say we want an approximate posterior.
Indeed, that's 4.13. This one here.
Okay. Okay, so this is just a a way of
notating that we want the posterior
overx that is close enough to the true
uh posterior. This one here.
Now, there's lots of different ways you
can do variational free [clears throat]
energy minimization. Um the way that
we're going to do it here is we're going
to do it kind of simply uh by means of
something called a uh a grid search. Not
a grid search. Um, coordinate search.
So, figure 4.2.
Uh,
is that here really quickly? I don't
think it is.
Free form evidence. Chapter 4.
Would be nice to show this
surpriseiterations.
No, too much.
I don't know if we have this
necessarily. Aha, perfect. There we go.
So, the idea is that we're going to say
that we are on some kind of surface that
characterizes our approximate posterior.
Okay. Well, what characterizes a post,
you know, a probability distribution?
Its parameters. Okay. And we've seen
that we're using Gaussian or normal
distributions for everything. So we're
going to have to talk about the mean and
the variance of our approximate
posterior distribution. Okay. So the
mean and the variance they kind of
constitute maybe you know two
coordinates for where our posterior
distribution is. And we're going to
think about the surface that constitutes
um the points that characterize our
approximate posterior. So it looks a bit
like this.
I should have got this up beforehand,
but this is a very nice figure to look
at. This is a paper by Carl Fristen and
many other people. Uh, not too important
to see what it talks about other than
the first figure. So,
this is kind of the situation. Imagine
that there's some surface, right? In
this case, it's this kind of shell thing
here. And each point on the surface is a
mean and a variance. It's a coordinate
that describes what the belief is at a
given place on the surface. So if you
walk if you walk along the surface, this
corresponds to changing parameters
either changing the mean or changing the
variance of our belief. So you can
imagine maybe a trajectory on this
surface corresponds to a process of
changing the belief across time. The
mean might move, the variance might
increase, might decrease. That's the
sort of setup we're going to imagine
that we're in. And what we're going to
do is we're going to come back here.
We're going to imagine that we can move
some small amount in each cardinal
direction. Okay? So we can say we're
currently at mu q sigma squ q, but we
could consider going up slightly in
terms of adding a little bit of kappa to
our variance or away from our variance.
Or instead we subtract kappa from the
mean. Okay? So we can take a step in
either norththeast west or northeast
northwest southeast southwest. And then
what we're going to do is we're going to
evaluate the free energy at all of these
points here and we're going to take a
step in the direction of the point that
has the minimum variational free energy.
And we're going to do this for a lot of
steps. So if we iterate this procedure
and we do this kind of optimization,
we're going to eventually find a point
on the surface that corresponds to an
approximate posterior Gaussian
approximate posterior that has minimum
variation for energy. Okay, so this is
again this is the optimization procedure
that we're saying. There's many other
ways to do this. This is a a sort of
nice simple way. So figure 4.3
I don't know if we have uh no we don't
want free form just yet. Well this is
we won't quite get to um this particular
point in the chapter today. I want
figure 4.3 which tells me G for model
comparisons prizal iterations. I think I
want this one. No not quite. I
apologize. VF history. This is probably
the right one.
>> Sorry. Uh, you're looking for the
figures from the textbook like 4.
>> I am. Yeah,
>> there should be in the I'm seeing them
in the code app.
>> Oh, really? Am I just
>> Yeah. Under under figures.
>> Oh dear. Maybe I I missed them.
>> Yeah. Uh, focus on the left hand far
left hand pages. Uh, scroll down to
figures which are just
>> above
the page yet. Okay. Okay. Thank you.
>> Yeah, no worries at all. Yeah,
[clears throat]
>> perfect.
>> Really building out this kod. So,
[gasps]
>> here we go.
>> Beautiful. So, this is what we're
looking at here.
So, the idea is we're going to look top
down on a surface. Hang on.
Okay. And and Daniel had a very nice way
of analogizing this surface to a
topographical map. So this is you know
these are the means here along the x
axis and these are the variances along
the y- axis and each point corresponds
to an approximate posterior distribution
and we can score those points according
to their VF. So kind of cold looking
colors are minimum or low VF and hot
looking colors are high VF and what
we're going to do is we're going to
start out somewhere on this surface.
Okay, somewhere um perhaps random. So
that's we're going to start here at
least that's where we're going to start
and then we're going to do coordinate
descent. We're just going to say, "All
right, look at all of the eight points,
choose the one with the minimum VF, take
a step in that direction." And we're
going to do that for a few steps,
basically. So, we can see that if we do
it in this problem, we end up going down
this way. So, we're minimizing VF here.
We get to this kind of valley, right?
So, this this thick black line, this is
the bottom of a of a valley. And then we
change direction and we start descending
further down to this valley here where
we actually get to the minimum. And then
this down here, this corresponds to our
final posterior belief after having done
maybe what is that maybe 20 steps of uh
well yeah 20 iterations of uh
variational free energy minimization
with coordinate descent. So on the right
here this is the same plot again except
now we're actually seeing the posterior
distribution. So this light yellow one
that's the initial one. Okay. And then
as we pro progress in time, you know,
take a step, take a step, take a step.
As we do this all the way to number 20,
where the purple one is the final one,
we're changing the shape of the
approximate posterior. And this one here
has the minimum. That's the key idea.
Now, in in an effort to maybe kind of
show this a little bit more visually or
or with a little bit more uh
uh movement, I have animated this
procedure in a very basic manner. If you
go to the chapter 4 notes
and you come up to here, I'll I'll put
this probably in the section notes
variational optimization. If we click on
this, hopefully everyone can see.
I've animated using kind of three blue
one browns package manim the process of
variational free energy minimization. So
what we have here this is our true
posterior belief P of X given Y. But
we're going to approximate this with um
an approximate posterior. So the first
iteration and I've inverted the colors
here. So you know dark colors are bad
and lighter colors are good. So the
first iteration of our Q it's quite bad.
But as we increase the number of
iterations you can see we're getting
closer and closer as we walk along that
um that surface to the true posterior.
So in the end we end up very very close
to the true posterior. It's not quite
ideal, um, but it's close enough. Okay,
and that's the idea. We're not going to
get exactly the true posterior usually.
We're going to get something close
enough is is the general idea. Now,
these animations, they can be made
interactive, which I think would be very
cool to see. But, um, hopefully that was
a bit more context as to to what's going
on basically.
Figures, figures, figures. But
definitely definitely um
uh well example 4.1 is is the canonical
example here. If you really understand
this you'll understand the um the core
of what's going on I would say. So there
is he does present the algorithm
algorithm 4 on page 83 coordinate search
minimization of variation for energy. Um
I don't want to go through that just
now.
That kind of takes us to section 4.3
which I think is really the the
intellectual kind of core of uh the
whole chapter basically like what are we
doing with all of this DF stuff is is
what 4.3 is about. Uh and there is this
figure
this one here actually do we go
we got enough points. Yeah.
So the idea here is that well section
4.3 variational free energy is an upper
bound on surprisal. Uh this is the
really key idea basically and there's
this figure. Uh perhaps it would be
better instead to look at this equation.
So we're going to look at figure well
4.7
because this motivates the idea. So in
this section we will investigate VF in
more detail to show figure well equation
4.7
where is that
this is uh I've already explained this
verbally but I want to spend a bit more
time on it now
maybe we don't have it for 7A B
is that right okay maybe we don't here
we go 21.
Oh, okay. They're they're named
differently. So, this is what I want to
show you, but it's not named correctly
just now.
Uh so the idea is that we want to show
that the negative log evidence is
approximately equal to uh the minimum
variational free energy that you get
when you put in the approximate
posterior belief to the variational free
energy functional. [laughter] A lot of
words there. So by the way a little bit
more nomenclature just in case it wasn't
enough. What you you'll often hear the
variational free energy talked about in
terms of a functional. Okay, so we've
seen functions before. We have
probability density functions here with
our approximate posterior and the the
generative model. A functional is a
function of functions.
So the variational for energy is a
functional basically. You you'll hear
this talked about in in many uh many
places.
But uh that brings us to the next form
of the VF which is uh important to to
meditate upon. So this is 4.18
the D form uh which I hope we have. We
should be up here
48.
There we go. Perfect.
So with a little bit of algebra you can
sort of rearrange things. We've seen
this though uh in previous steps. This
is the expression for the variational
free energy again in terms of a
divergence. So this is where the D in in
the D form comes from. So we've seen the
variational free energy. It's a
divergence between the approximate and
true posterior minus the surprisal or
the log evidence or the marginal
evidence. All of these terms surprisal
marginal evidence log model evidence
these are all equivalent. Okay. So which
is a bit confusing. Um but that is to
say that there is a very profound
relationship between the log model
evidence or the surprisal and the
variational free energy and as I said
before the variational free energy
bounds surprisal it's always uh kind of
less than the surprisal basically
so that that brings us I'm just mindful
of time that brings us to figure 4.5
I want to go here and there's much more
to be said about this which I don't
think we will have time in session to
talk about figure 4.5. This is what I
show showed before just really briefly.
Whoops.
Okay. So, let's imagine we have
observations on the x axis. We have
probability on the y axis. So, looking
at this this panel over here, this is
the marginal uh for this is the
observation margin. This is the the
model evidence right here. Okay. Um so,
it's a probability distribution as
before. It tells us the probability of
an observation uh given our model and
everything. The surprisal is sort of
like the uh the inverse of this. It
tells us how strange it would be to
observe something given our model. Okay?
And that's over here in the middle. So
you see the the most plausible the most
probable observation in terms of the
marginal evidence is the least
surprising state. Okay. Okay, so if our
model is predicting observations
um with a high probability, they would
be not very surprising because we
predicted them well. Okay, but you see
out here in the extremes, our model is
not predicting these observations with
very much at all. Those would be very
very highly surprising to observe. Okay,
so that's
intuitively what the relationship is
between model evidence and surprisal. um
they're kind of like inverses of one
another. And what he's done in the the
right se uh panel here is plot the model
evidence against the surprisal. So you
can see if you have very very high fine
model evidence you have low surprisal.
If you have very low model evidence, you
have very high surprisal. That's the uh
the idea.
It's a he says okay so if we take the
negative of the observation well p of y
the marginal on observations we obtain
surprisal. Surprisal captures the
unexpectedness of sensory observations
for the agent given a model. Okay,
always given a model basically.
And that takes us to example 4.2.
Surprisal and marginal likelihood. Um
that's probably where we're going to
have to end up today. So that's figure
4.6.
This is so I would I would say figure
4.3 and figure 4.6. These are the two
big conceptual things to understand in
this chapter. I think maybe we're going
to have to stop there. Maybe we can take
some questions uh and then next time we
can take off the rest of this section
because there's not a lot to finish out
and then the rest of the sections are
you know we have intuition for other
forms of variational free energy and
then we talk about two different ways of
um doing or two different ways of
approximating variational free energy
minimization or making our lives easier
and that brings us to the end of the
chapter.
So
let's come back. Yeah.
very very uh this as I say this is a
really important chapter. This is a very
central piece of the mathematical
machinery that we're going to be using
over and over and over again um
throughout the entire book. So it's
extremely important this variational
free energy minimization business and
we're going to see many different ways
to do it. Um there are lots of different
ways you know and uh coordinate search
is just one of them. Uh but it is going
to be utterly central to everything that
we do uh going forward.
So, okay, maybe the last couple of
minutes here. If there are any live
questions, please feel free to uh fire
away and then probably we'll stop the
recording and we can have some anonymous
questions. So,
and as I say, we'll uh [clears throat]
we will go through and uh answer
questions in the actual uh questions
tab. So, the best way to do that, yeah,
go down to here on the left hand side.
So questions, add a question. And you
know, we're in chapter four, so you'll
have to come down here.
Questions, comments, queries. Was
anything unclear? Is there anything that
anyone would like me to go over again in
the next session or such like? So
I see in the chat.
Thank you, Andrew, for uh being chat
man.
>> H yes, Professor Strang MIT. Yeah,
great. That's an excellent uh Thank you,
Ahmad. So,
I totally agree. Uh anything by
Professor Strang is always very good.
>> Gradient descent downhill to a minimum.
This is excellent. I'll put this in the
maybe supplementary material. Carrie,
you've got a question.
>> Make sure there we go. Not so much a
question, but just wanting to clarify
that I heard um the way that you set up
the beginning of the chapter, which was
that um that the problem that we're
solving is that we don't know what we
don't know. Is that an accurate way to
reference
that we're
>> and that's why we make that shift to
optimization
>> basically. Yes. So the problem is the
the inference problem that we're dealing
with is just in general too hard pretty
much as as I as I said before. So we're
that motivates why we're going to try
and turn it into a different kind of
problem, an optimization problem.
Absolutely. Yeah. I I I you've
understood.
>> Yeah, this this question comes up very
frequently. I think it's a very good
question that should be repeated and and
discussed. um is I I'm saying this as
well for those who are coming from like
more of a a machine learning background
or otherwise too. The question we've
already been asked this question
multiple times in like the previous
sessions from previous chapters as well.
It's like we don't know the true
environment. And so if you like for
those who are doing machine learning and
things like that, sometimes this is
uncomfortable because we're so used to
looking at these supervised learning
problems where we have a bunch of nice
data in advance. Um and and so we're
just kind of like trying to get our
model to be like really good based on on
all of that sort of curated initial
data. And it's like we kind of could
know the true environment. But if we
think about this more in terms of
everyday reality like you know a child
is born they don't know the environment
there's no no way of communicating to
the child like every little bit of how
this works and let alone knowing it. It
doesn't none of that follows like the
basian brain hypothesis none of that
follows like you know common views in
cognitive science psychology etc. We
have to figure out the world around us.
So I guess I'm trying to summarize this
by saying like we never know the true
environment and so we have to start with
some kind of prior guess what what that
guess kind of looks like what is the
shape of it how did things work and then
from there we do have we we start kind
of optimizing it and refining it um so I
hope that that's kind of a useful
understanding that not just for you who
asked the question but like other people
in general as well like we cannot know
the true environment like it's just sort
of a fundamental aspect of this rather
than it being a problem with the basian
framework or acuperence or something
like that.
>> Vera, did you uh did you want to ask
something?
>> Uh yes. So basically the G form helps us
um to locate the best approximate
posterior
and the D form is shows us the process
what what happens when the K KL
divergence is reduced. Did I understood
that correctly? Did I understand that
correctly?
Yeah, I mean basically yes, there the
idea is that they're kind of two
different aspects as I say on the same
uh the same underlying quantity. So
they're they they emphasize different
things that are important about the
variational free energy. I don't know to
scroll here. So yeah, the idea with the
the G form is that we're expressing the
variational free energy in terms of
things that we know. So we know our
approximate posterior, we know the
generative model. That means it's
something that we can calculate. That's
the important thing about the G form and
hopefully I'm sharing my screen here but
the the D form the divergence form which
was here
that is showing us that the variational
free energy is a divergence between
things that we know and this thing this
other thing that we don't know the the
log model evidence and that we can put a
bound on the log model evidence. So yes
you've understood correctly.
Okay. So that means that uh the upper
bound is the free energy and the lower
bound is the surprisal and the
difference between is the K KL
divergence. Is that right?
>> Well the so in the in the D form I want
to I do want to share because it is
important. The in the D form the
divergence is between the this is very
annoying how that happens. Hopefully I'm
still sharing. Uh so there's the G form.
I want the D form. this one here, the
divergence is between the approximate
posterior and the true posterior. Uh but
we can't know that. Uh the thing that is
needed to correct this whole thing is
the surprisal. So what what we actually
end up calculating is the G form. This
one up here. So this because we can we
can directly evaluate this. But we know
that the relationship between this and
the G form, you know, they're just two
aspects on the same thing. So if we can
calculate this and make it very small,
then in the D form
here,
so we make this divergence between the
approximate triper very small, we're
going to get something that's close to
the log uh model evidence. Okay? And
that's the thing that we need to
calculate if we're going to do Beijian
inference. So I I hope that answers your
question there. Um
the the thing the thing to emphasize is
that they're just different aspects on
the same quantity.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Actually, Fraser, do you mind? I just
added another figure for chapter 4. Um
>> Oh, yes.
>> Yeah. I think I think Daniel didn't add
it because the the figure doesn't
actually have like a figure 4 point such
and such. Um but it's just um Yeah. So,
it's under figures.
not equations. Um,
>> so you are you are seeing my screen.
Perfect. Y figures and four.
>> Let me
>> uh so so figures on the
>> Sorry, hang on. I can't be expected to
navigate a computer. Uh I only spend all
day doing that. [laughter]
>> No, [clears throat] no worries. Yeah. So
So far left hand.
>> Yes. Thank you. And then at the bottom
of chapter 4, um,
>> and if you just click that,
>> um, so this is the nice summary of these
different forms of free energy that
we'll we'll see in different ways going
forward. Um,
I think he's actually with this figure,
he wrote G just a bit differently. Um
but you you can kind of see in these
different ways like there are different
ways that we can kind of shape this
function without actually changing the
the genuine terms upon which it relies.
So all these kind of generally work in
the same way. Um and then uh the the
phrasing with the question earlier is
generally correct that the the the upper
bound is is variational free energy or
or um in the sense that it's it's sort
of always greater than or equal to
surprisal and then surprisal itself does
become sort of like a like a a lower
bound like this is the the minimum that
our model can achieve at this point in
time. um it's simply intractable and
that is the the difference. So the whole
idea is that we're trying to reduce our
free energy until we can reach
surprisal. Um do we ever know if we've
actually achieved that? No, not
necessarily. But the the the benefit and
why we do this is that it is still
guaranteed that the variational free
energy is greater than or equal to
surprisal. If we're bringing down
variational free energy, we're
necessarily approaching the surprisal.
And then the next issue after that is
well what if we do sort of miraculously
achieve zero divergence such that
variational free energy now does align
with surprisal like we've reached that
global bottom. Well, now the next
limitation is how good is your model?
Because if surprisal itself is lower
bound is still quite high, you still
might not have a very good model, right?
And that's that's the importance of not
just having inference but also having
learning that is you you you improve
your model its ability to infer you
improve its parameters and then that is
what will kind of bring down that that
surprisal as a lower bound as well. So
you can I know it's it sounds a bit uh
elaborate but it's our way it the true
goal is to minimize surprisal but
knowing that we can't directly compute
that due to that intractability of model
evidence and and how that plays out in
surprisal surprisal just being the
negative log of model evidence. Um we
have to instead kind of reduce this
variational free energy term that's
something that is tractable. It allows
us to like genuinely check to see if our
model is improving and then from there
we just continue with learning.
Hopefully our model improves even
further from there.
>> It's actually two typos on the diagram.
>> I was just looking that at that as well.
This feature is at the end of chapter 4.
Um, we might want to report that as a
Ara. I think it would be much more
useful, by the way, to use the X rather
than the VA theta. I'm not clear on why
he brought up bar theta suddenly. Here's
>> I I think the bar theta is fine. It's
just more generic, but there's two typos
in the D form. Second line from the top.
Uh the first is that brace that
indicates surprisal should span towards
the left to also include the minus sign.
And the second typo there is it's not
minus log p of var theta. It's minus log
of p y.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. Because it's the
marginal evidence of observation. So we
we've swapped out var theta for x here
which is confusing but no I I agree
those are those are two irasa and the
surprisal as kobus mentioned it is
negative log model evidence so it should
really include that whole minus sign
yeah we'll fix those we'll put them in
the arta yeah
>> it's also handy to for me at least to
consider the first three forums
all three
in terms of starting with a divergence
so that means for the g forum um to view
it as the um KL divergence of uh Q var
theta relative to uh the generative
model and then it aligns nicely with a D
form and C form which uh also start with
a divergence term only the E form is not
in terms of uh divergence terms.
>> No, I I agree. I mean we haven't we
actually haven't seen the latter two
just yet. So if you're for anyone who's
wondering, you know, we haven't seen the
the the DNA just yet, but we will see
them um later on in 4.4 onwards. So
yeah,
very nice. Uh I should make a note for
myself for the Arata. So I don't think
that's in there. It's not in there just
yet. Okay, very good to know. So
uh cool. Any other questions?
Think weird maybe or
not not not mathematical question about
the the idea behind the free energy.
My favorite form to be honest is the C
form
as complexity and accuracy. This is the
only form I was able to kind of map to
intuitive understanding. The complexity
can be thought of
would you have to change your beliefs to
matchations that you get. So Andrew
brought up an example of a child. This
is probably one of the best examples.
How would child explain what what he
sees?
He
do a lot of updates to his knowledge
about the world to explain some new
observation
and the other point the other part of it
is the accuracy. So he makes predictions
based on his internal model. How well
these predictions match the observations
he gets. So together this sort of gives
us the free energy that variation of
free energy that is we are trying to
minimize. I fail to understand how that
possibly can work
in reality. I mean we don't have access
to any real distributions like there is
nothing we are building it up from
scratch like I mean there are some
theories from like Gorgi Busaki
the model that we build uh inside our
brains or in neoortex they are based on
sort of already pre-existing topology of
like signals might travel but that still
is explained like there is no math
no distribution to work with. This is
just all completely approximate. I
failed to map the actual formulas to you
know
>> that is that's actually one thing we'll
see in chapter five on predictive coding
because there's this question about well
how does as you say how does the brain
biological entities how do they actually
do any of this if they are doing any of
this in some sense they would have to
encode probability distributions you
know maybe the sufficient statistics
thereof or something like that it's
unclear if they're really doing that or
if this is merely a way to model a
plausible story about what they could be
doing or what they might be doing. So
there is a debate an ongoing debate
about yeah exactly
are are there literalists who say look
you know the brain is literally
instantiating these probability
distributions and is doing Beijian
inference of this kind or is this just a
convenient story about how it might be
flavored in some sense you know so that
is that is a very a very deep question
one that we'll see as I say in chapter
five because chapter five is all about
um you know a process theory about how
this could happen uh plausibly so yeah
yeah but You're you're you're very right
to to highlight especially for people
who come from a sort of machine learning
background. Complexity and accuracy are
two very salient and familiar ideas that
motivate what the VF can be at all. Um
uh we'll we'll we'll go into them in in
the next session because they sort of
show up there. Andrew, did you want to
just want to comment on something?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Just to briefly because I
think you nailed it in your your answer
there, Frasier. Um but this is also
something that came up frequently in pre
the previous 2022 textbook group. you
know what once we do start getting into
like well well what what was the
starting point right like what is the
origin here and active inference doesn't
necessarily provide you know it it's not
particularly satisfying to hear but uh
active inference is attempting to
provide a sort of account whether it you
know again it's still a debate does the
brain onetoone do exactly what we're
describing here or does it do something
like this like it's sort of it's as if
it's doing basian inference that's still
still clearly like a broad debate that's
being had not just within active
inference and between active inference
and other fields it's being had in other
fields too the basian brain hypothesis
did not come from active inference it's
the other way around so um you know so
so that's a matter of discussion and
then importantly active inference does
not try to provide that origin story of
like well you know for the for the
infant who's just been born or even
before being born right they still in
the womb like we don't know like what
what would be sort of the shape of the
priors that that infant has. Um but I I
love that you brought up Busousaki
actually. I was that that's part of what
got me into neuroiming and all the rest
before I even knew what active inference
was. And uh yeah, it's a good it's a
good point. I mean, we start looking
more at sort of biology and neurobiology
and theories of like, well, what kinds
of sort of sort of instincts to put it
more simply or or what kind of cognitive
architecture are are humans born with
that would you know what is that so that
we could determine like what are those
initial priors that that infant has so
to speak or how could we even try to
model that? Still a very good question
and know but Musaki does refer to the
idea that there are these like common
neuronal signatures that it relates to
um kind of the connectivity that we
already have and that would that's our
initial originary machinery that we have
to get get started. But
>> just riffing on that I mean one one very
powerful thing that we'll see uh again
probably starting with predictive coding
this idea of models being hierarchical.
So you know we can have quite you know
many the idea of the prior structure
that is inherited comes from different
layers of the model and this is kind of
distributed throughout those layers in
some sense. That's a very powerful idea
that um actually instantiates or is used
to instantiate these kinds of models for
sure. Yeah. Yeah. I tell you what guys
I'm going to end the recording just just
now but anyone who wants to stay around
for a few more minutes and talk they're
free to do so. So thank you very much.
Uh we will see you next time YouTube
people. Peace out.